je suis opposé aux occupations illégales
mais mais mais pour les rendre légal il
ya un moyen simple je vous l'annonçais
je vais donc interdire à l'urbanisation
cette partie des lentillères par contre
je vais aussi demander l'évacuation de
tous ceux qui occupent de manière
illégale ce terrain vous voyez les deux
choses et pourront ils faire des jardins
partagés des maraîchages urbain ceux qui
s'inscriront pour avoir un bail
il faudra donc avoir un bail des baux
seront concédées par la ville de dijon
parce qu'on occupe pas les terrains
illégalement ils appartiennent à la
ville des gens mais ils ne seront pas
soumis à urbanisation ses dix hectares
ainsi qu'ils seront retirés de
l'urbanisation